Welcome to the podcast Ufo, your weekly joy and pleasure for your soul. Where jokes feel like home
And the presenters are best known.
Welcome to the podcast UFO. Welcome to the podcast Late Night Edition. We're gonna lead you through the night, talk about random stuff and listen to some great music. Diese Folge ist präsentiert von Warmsteiner Kaffee. Ist der warm, so warm wie ein Stein in der Brandung. Ich probiere einen jetzt gerade in diesem Moment und der schmeckt fantastisch. Warmsteiner Kaffee. Schön, dass du da bist, Stefan. Nein, schön, dass du da bist, Valentin. Schön, dass du da bist. Hast jetzt mir aber einen Konter entgegengeworfen. Vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder reingeschneit bist. Ja. Wir haben uns leider nicht hier im Büro getroffen, sondern dabei jetzt unten auf der Strasse.
Ja, das ist immer ein bisschen unangenehm.
Scheiße, sag wie es ist. Es ist so ein bisschen
wie Clark Kent, bevor er zum
Superman wird, wenn irgendwie so Doktor Octopus
oder so um die Ecke kommt und er so, ah
shit, ich bin noch mit
so einem Kaffeebecher in der Hand und
hat noch so ein Handy am Telefon und so
und denkst dir, oh nee, jetzt,
oh Gott, jetzt muss ich wieder. Es ist wie
so ein, wenn man sein Handy lädt
und man zieht den Stecker raus, bevor es ganz
Vielen Dank. Hat noch so ein Handy am Telefon und so und denkst dir, oh nee, jetzt, oh Gott, jetzt muss ich, ja. Es ist wie so ein, wenn man sein Handy lädt und man zieht den Stecker raus, bevor es ganz geladen hat. Man ist so, der Sozialakku ist noch nicht ganz aufgeladen und plötzlich sehe ich deine Fresse da langlaufen. Und dann begrüsst man sich und man weiß, weil wir beide kennen uns gut, wir beide wissen, wir sind noch nicht bereit für diesen Moment gerade. Wir beide wissen auch, dass unser Büro um siebzehnten Stock ist, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt siebzehn Stockwerke hochlaufen und Treppensteigen ohnehin schon mal eine körperliche Maximalleistung für mich. Also ich glaube, wenn man so meinen Herzschlag anzeigt, man kann genau die Treppengänge in der Woche genau gut isolieren, von den Daten her, da natürlich noch ein ulkiges Gespräch mit einem Kollegen, während die Luft immer knapper wird. Und man noch ein Brötchen isst, und man sich noch schnell ein Brötchen reinschiebt. Wo die Luftwege eh noch halb gefüllt sind vom Zimtwuppi, und man dann eh kaum noch atmen kann, und man sagt, ja, ich schätze mal, Kollaps irgendwo zwischen Stock acht und neun. Warum können die Ohren nicht auch Luft aufsaugen? Weil, wenn man die Treppen hochgeht, brauche ich alle Luftlöcher, alle Luftschleusen, die ich bekommen kann. Alle Körperöffnungen auf. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn der Mund voll ist, wenn man sich noch ein Brötchen reinballert, dann ist nicht mehr so viel da, dann ist die Nase, die ist oft zu, gerade zur Pollensaison ist die oft zu. Ich plädiere, Ohren. Ohren müssen mehr Gewicht tragen in unserer Welt, Ohren müssen sich mehr reinhängen. Oder geht das jetzt nicht, weil da das Trommelfell spannt? Ich glaube, mit ein paar gezielten Stichen kann man da durchaus Wege frei machen, das ist kein Problem. Du bist ja der Experte, du kennst dich im Innenohr gut aus. Ich kenne das Innenohr, ich kenne alle Abbiegungen, es gibt ein paar Ausfahrten, denen ich noch nicht nachgegangen bin, also ich weiß nicht, wohin die führen, aber es gibt schon noch ein paar kleine Geheimgänge, da muss man an so einer kleinen Minifackel ziehen und dann geht so eine kleine Öffnung auf und so. ich weiss nicht, wohin die führen, aber es gibt schon noch ein paar kleine Geheimgänge, da muss man so eine kleine Minifackel ziehen und dann geht so eine kleine Öffnung auf und so. Ich weiß nicht, wohin die führt, Milz vielleicht, keine Ahnung, eine kleine Abkürzung. Ja, die sind im Innenohrbereich, das weiß ja jeder, dass die Milz da hängt. Ich meine, der Körper hat ja auch Cheatcodes, so du musst ja auch manchmal, wenn gewisse Blutkörperchen schnell in die Milz und so und her, ich kenne einen Weg, echt? Und dann so der alte Veteran-Blutkörperchen, der vier Minuten alt ist, kann dem neuen Blutkörperchen, das eine Minute alt ist, zeigen, ja, hier ist der Geheimgang, da kommt man durch. Das wird doch mal geil, eine Mario-Kart-Strecke durch den Körper. Man wird vorher geschrumpft, das ist eine kleine spaßige Animation, und dann ist man im Körper. Aber über wessen Körper? Über welchen? Peaches. Tschüss. Oh Gott. Das kam so schnell, als ob du das schon mal in einer kurzen Kurzgeschichte verarbeitet hättest, diesen Traum. Ihr könnt ja mal nachschauen auf literotica.com. Mario Kart Fanfiction. Erotische Mario Kart Fanfiction. Da gibt es nur einen einzigen Autor. Esteban. Ja genau, Esteban Totze. Aber der schreibt ganz toll. Er verrennt sich ein bisschen in Mario-Kart-Spezifika. In den Power-Ups, ja. Wer jetzt genau den roten Panzer hat und so. Und er regt sich auch sehr doll auf, dass Mario nicht die besten Items bekommt. Aber ja, die Strecke muss man sich vorstellen, geht über, also man muss sich vorstellen, Peach liegt, sie ist.
Ich glaube, wir können das alles nachlesen, also wenn Leute Interesse haben.
Nee, sie wurde, nein, nein, das ist gar nicht.
So eine schlafende Peach. Aber okay, alles klar.
Gut, wir fahren quasi auf dem Körper.
Also herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO, die perverse Stimme, die ihr schon die ganze Zeit gehört habt, Stefan Mariatice.
Hiiii.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Hey, da ist er doch. Schön, dass du da bist, Mensch.
Und deine Stimme kenne ich auch.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen, Furentin will.
Richtig, korrekt. Du hattest drei im Kopf, ich war es dann tatsächlich. Schön, dass du da bist. Und ich bin nass. Es regnet ein bisschen. Ja, es regnet doll. Das nervt mich sehr. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr, das zu ertragen. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, was ich dagegen tun soll, ausser drinbleiben. Also ich kann mich darüber aufregen. Ich kann mich so doll über Regen aufregen. Ja? Ja. Es ist auch von mir selber peinlich, wie sehr ich mich darüber aufrege, weil es einfach, es regnet halt sehr häufig. Wie viel Prozent aller Tage regnet es?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich
mache immer, was ich gerne mache,
ich mag Hunde bei Regen,
die im Park sind. Weil die so gut riechen.
Und einfach Lavendel.
Weil die einfach fucking schlechte Laune haben.
Und ich finde das irgendwie richtig lustig.
Hunde, die einfach so, wie so eine Art
Montag, so ein klassischer, ich trotte
zur Arbeit, ich hab keinen Bock.
Sie rennen auch nicht. Sie rennen nicht, sie spielen
nicht, sie müssen da jetzt einfach
Vielen Dank. die einfach so wie so eine art so ein montag so ein klassischer ich trotte zur arbeit ich habe keinen bock sie rennen auch nicht sie rennen nicht sie spielen nicht sie müssen da jetzt einfach durch und manche haben auch diesen diese albernen regenmäntel an die einfach so demütigend aussehen die einfach auch nicht mal cool aussehen sondern sie sind und vor allem ich habe manchmal in den augen des hundes denke ich mir eigentlich wollte ich heute gar nichtieren gehen, aber ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt nicht gewollt hätte, hätte mein Mensch nicht gecheckt, dass es wegen Regen ist und wir würden sonst auch weniger gehen. Also muss ich jetzt so tun, als hätte ich mega Bock auf Spazieren gehen, um Tue so, damit wir immer gerne spazieren gehen. So dieses, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich habe keinen Bock, denkt der, ich habe nie generell keinen Bock. Genau.
Ich kann das kommunikativ nicht gut unterscheiden, was ich gerade
heute keine Lust drauf habe.
Generell ein großes Problem, was ich habe, was ich merke,
was in mir schlummert, ist,
ich kann mich nicht gut ausdrücken. Mir fehlen
teilweise Fähigkeiten, mich richtig ausdrücken.
Ich habe meinen Schwanz, der wedelt. Wenn ich
fröhlich bin, mehr habe ich nicht.
Mein Gesicht kann einen Ausdruck und ich kann den Kopf leicht neigen. Das mache ich inzwischen auch super gern, wenn ich soziale Dinge nicht verstehe, wenn man gegenüber etwas sagt und ich verstehe es nicht genau, mache ich den oder ich rede gerade und gegenüber macht eine Geste oder sowas, die ich nicht verstehe, höre ich auf, wie Hunde dann zu sprechen. Also die sprechen nicht, aber hören auf mit ihren Interaktionen oder ihren Tätigkeiten. Ich höre auf zu sprechen und lege dann meinen Kopf schräg, weil das Hunde auch machen, um mehr Informationen zu bekommen, finde ich fantastisch. Ich glaube, du kannst ein komplettes Gespräch für nötige Kopffosition. Es gibt dieses Ah ne, das ist in den Nacken fallen lassen, wenn was und dann gehe ich da hin und dann stand da schon jemand auf meinem Parkplatz. Oh, Kopf nach hinten. Kopf nach hinten, in den Nacken. Und dann wieder, auch wenn, konzentriert nach vorne. Ich glaube, man könnte ein komplettes Videospiel machen, wo man nur mit dem Joystick die Kopfposition wählt, um richtig zuzuhören. Da ist alles schon drin. Kunde, Kunde. Hunde checken nichts. Ich dachte, so heißt das Videospiel., Kunde. Kunde, Hunde, Kunde, aber Hunde checken nicht unbedingt, dass zunächst, dass Menschen mit dem Gesicht kommunizieren, sondern denken halt, die sind wie andere Hunde und kommunizieren mit dem Körper. Macht aber Menschen kaum. Menschen, alles passiert im Gesicht, alles passiert auf diesem kleinen 20 mal 20 cm Feld, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, und bei Hunden halt nicht. Und das finde ich so spannend, weil es ist so anders als Menschen, aber trotzdem kriegen wir es irgendwie hin, gemeinsam zu kommunizieren. Irgendwie klappt es dann doch. Naja, außer du hast recht, also Hunde müssten dann so tun, als würden sie gerne durch den Regen laufen. Ja genau, anstatt dass sie zu sagen können, na heute regnet es heute mal nicht, sondern müssen sie sagen, immer oder immer nicht. Ich glaube, die halten uns Menschen auch für viel dümmer als, also an alle Hunde, ich glaube, wir haben da noch ein bisschen mehr drauf. Aber ich habe tatsächlich soziale Interaktionen diese Woche sehr unangenehm, und zwar habe ich mir ein Fahrrad gekauft. Ein Fahrrad, der Kau? Ich bin mobil, ich bin mobil, ja, ich bin schnell. Was habe ich dir doch empfohlen, du hast mich ausgelacht. Richtig, aber den Fehler, den du gemacht hast, ich habe es mir nicht in Köln gekauft, sondern in Hamburg. Ja, es ist ein Fehler, den ich gemacht habe. Hamburg und ich dachte mir, komm... Es ist ein Fehler, den ich gemacht habe, mir in einer Stadt, in der ich nicht wohne, kein Fahrrad zu kaufen. Das war echt ein großer Fehler. Und ich dachte mir, es wird eh geklaut. Ich hab eh das Gefühl, man kauft Fahrräder nicht, man leiht sie. Ich hab deswegen literally ein Fahrrad geliehen. Ja, genau, weil jedes Fahrrad ist nur geliehen. Es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis es geklaut ist. Aber heißt Lein, dass du es auch geklaut hast? Ich sag mal, du musst das Spiel schon mit Spielen zu überleben. Don't hate the player. Blame the gamer, not blame the game. Blame the blamer, not the blame. Not the blade. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, kaufst du dir ein richtig schäbiges eBay-Kleinanzagen? Ich wollte so einen richtigen Drahtesel. Ich habe auch eingegeben bei eBay-Kleinanzagen Drahtesel, da ist da nicht viel gekommen, was ich schade fand.
Es kam so Kreisverkehr-Kunst, stell ich mir vor.
Wirklich ein Litschel-Drahtesel.
So etwas, was wir über den Stein stellen.
Wir geben unseren Drahtesel ab.
Nächstes Litschelin-Drahtesel.
Von Igor Knavadovic, der Künstler, der hier mal was rausholen konnte. Er hat dann diesen Drahtesel, der stand lange da auf dem Kreisverkehr. Da Aachener trifft mehr auf Maisbergstrasse und der muss jetzt weg. Aber Leute dachten, sie kriegen Fahrrad, weil sie Drahtesel bekommen. Die Kreisverkehrskunst ist immer so, da gibt es keine Notes. Man könnte es vielleicht noch mal gucken, weil der ist ja jetzt porthässlich geworden. Nein, keine Notes. Ich bekomme keine Notes. Krasamowitsch kriegt keine Notes. Krasamowitsch gibt ab, erster Entwurf ist immer richtig. Willst du Kreisverkehrskunst, ich mache den Kreisverkehrskunst. Alles klar, dann bau den so. Hugo, kannst du kurz mal reinkommen? Ja klar.
Hugo, du bist jetzt schon lange mein Chief of Staff, schön, dass du da bist.
Du, Neustadt-Brockbach braucht dich und dein Fiat Punto.
Du hast doch gesagt, dass du dir letzte Woche ein neues Auto gekauft hast.
Genau, Fiat Punto 2.
Du kennst doch den Kreisverkehr da bei der Stadtausfahrt in den Wald.
Ja klar, der leer ist, wo bislang kein Kunstwerk.
Da wird bald ein Drahtesel draufstehen.
Ein Fahrrad?
Nein, ein Esel aus Draht. Es ist irgendeine postkolonialistische Botschaft der Ausbeutung.
Etwa ein echter Krasamowitsch?
Richtig. Und zwar, der wird nächste Woche installiert … Etwa ein echter Krasamowitsch? Richtig.
Und zwar, der wird nächste Woche installiert.
Ich brauche dich eine Woche später.
Du wirst auf diesen Kreisverkehr zufahren.
Du wirst dir denken, oh, ich biege ab nach rechts.
Du wirst nicht nach rechts abbiegen. Ich tue es nicht, ja.
Du fährst auf den Esel zu.
Mit der vollen Geschwindigkeit, die dein Fiat Brunto rausholt.
Das sind gute und gerne 53 kmh. Und du haust das Ding um, okay? Den Drahtesel? Du haust das Ding um und lass es wie ein Unfall aussehen, okay? Ist nicht gefährlich? Nicht für den Drahtesel. Eben, ist meine Angst. Danke. Ja, okay, ciao.
Auf Hugo kann man sich verlassen. Hugo, die Abenteuer des Hugos, die Vorstand-Abenteuer des kleinen Hugos. Der so ein kleines Auto hat. Und dann auf grosse Abenteuer, auf grosse Reise geschickt wird dann trotzdem. Und ja, ich wollte einen richtigen Drahtesel, ich wollte so ein richtig schäbiges Teil haben und dann habe ich ein richtig billiges Ding gefunden. Und dann ist das... Aber bist du so, war es zu verschenken billig oder war es... Nein, nein, nein, da waren schon in einem mittelhohen zweistelligen Betrag. Okay. Ich sag mal, so ein Schein musste den... Also mehrere Scheine mussten den Besitzer wechseln. Das ist auch noch ein Thema. Weil tatsächlich, soziale Dinge sind eine Herausforderung für mich und das ist für mich wie ein Urlaubplan, ist diesen Terminplan mit dem Fahrradverkäufer. Weil erstmal war wichtig, ich will das Geld exakt passend haben. Hat er gesagt. Nee, nee, ich wollte nur, ich wollte nicht in die Verlegenheit kommen, dass es jetzt, sagen wir mal, 65 Euro kostet und ich so, ja, ich habe jetzt eine 100 und dann, ja, ich kann ihn aber nicht rausgeben. Ja, nee, will man nicht. Und dann musste ich, weil ich hatte das Geld nicht passend in bar, dann musste ich zum Supermarkt gehen, wollte da aber auch nicht fragen, können Sie mir das Geld wechseln, sondern ich musste exakt präzise so einkaufen, dass der Betrag genau so funktioniert, dass ich das anscheinend rauskriege. Ich habe einen Fünfer gebraucht und einen Zwanziger. Du kannst zum Geldautomaten gehen und 25 Euro eingeben. Nicht in der Nähe, nicht in der Nähe, nicht in der Nähe, nicht in der Nähe, nicht in der Nähe. Ich weiß, wo du wohnst. Nicht in Hamburg. Und dann musste ich genau richtig einkaufen und es war schwierig, weil ich wollte mir einen Smoothie machen und musste so Früchte genau passen sein.
Und jetzt wird es schwer, jetzt wird es komplex, weil du hast nur einen Spielraum von fünf Euro. Wenn es jetzt irgendwie zehn Euro zehn kostet, geil, wenn es 16 Euro kostet, raus, kriegst du keinen Fünfer mehr. Das heisst rechts bei dir in der Questleiste stand, besorge so viel Früchte, dass du genau 25 Euro rausbekommst, aber noch damit immerhin noch einen Smoothie machen kannst. Genau. Der im Idealfall und da gibt es dann die fünf Sterne, wenn es gut klappt, auch noch schmeckt. Genau, das war der Highscore und da musste ich mich durcharbeiten und ich sag mal so, ich hab's gennailt. Das war so ein gutes Gefühl, wirklich, ich ich glaube, es waren am Ende wirklich 10,30 Euro oder so. Und genau die 30 Cent. Und dann fragt sie an der Kasse so, haben Sie 30 Cent passend? Und ich so, nein, leider nicht. Warum grinsen Sie dabei? Da müssen Sie mir jetzt leider ein Fünfer rausgeben. Oh, da muss ich nicht ein Fünfer rausgeben. Das ganze Kleingeld, schade. Und währenddessen so in meinem Notizblock, Quester abgeschlossen. Und dann denkst du, krass, ich habe diese super aufwendige Aufgabe abgeschlossen. Und dann fragt die Frau Kassiererin beim Rewe, fragt dann, wollen sie noch Geld abheben? Weil das kannst du einfach auch machen. So, und dann hatte ich das Geld auf jeden Fall da. Und man muss über mich wissen, ich bin der Anti-Falscher. Ich würde in meinem Leben nie feilschen, ich will nicht verhandeln, nichts. Ich gehe da hin und zahle den Betrag und aus. Für mich ist VB V. Einfach, es gibt kein B, es gibt kein, selbst V ist fragwürdig. Für mich ist der Preis einfach der Preis. Ist VB nicht Verhandlungsbasis? Ich will nur Basis. Dann bist du nur B. Gib mir nur Basis. Preisbasis. Preisbasis. Einfach Basis. Ich will einfach nur Preis. Wir haben nur P. Einfach nur Preis. Und dann hatte ich das Geld passend da, habe all meinen Mut zusammengenommen, habe mir überlegt, was sagt man, hallo, ja, guten Tag. Und dann wirklich die Situation, ich gehe da hin und es ist so ein klassisches Stadthaus, mehrstöckig, gehe da hin im zweiten Stock und ich mache die Tür auf und ich stehe plötzlich auf einem Bazar. Der Mann macht mir auf und sagt, oh, da sind sie, da ist ja schon das Prachtstück, ach, hier steht's schon, richtig edel, da wollten drei andere Leute, wollten heute schon vorbeikommen, aber ich habe es extra für die Reservierung, ich dachte mir, oh Gott, ich will es einfach nur haben. Und er so, so, dann machen wir jetzt folgendes, ich ziehe mir schnell die Schuhe an, dann trage ich sie ihn runter. Oh nein, nein, nein. Und ich dachte mir, nee, nee, ist okay. Und ich habe da schon versucht, nee, nee, ich nehme die, habe es noch nicht richtig reinbekommen. Und er so, ja, wunderbar, Schuhe an, Jacke an, pack den Drahtesel und dann so, gehen Sie einfach unten und machen Sie mir die Tür auf, dann trage ich ihn schon mal runter. Oh, das Bratstück ist auch gar nicht so schwer. Und ich denke mir, spar dir das alles. Du brauchst mir nichts mehr verkaufen. Spar dir das alles. Ich habe das Geld wirklich passend. Es ist gar nicht mehr möglich für mich, den Preis zu verändern. Ich habe es da. Gehe drunter und dann stehen wir da vor seinem Haus und dann so, so ja, also hier ist die Bremse, hier ist die Schaltung. Ja, ich hab in meinem Leben schon mal ein Fahrrad gesehen. Oh, drei Gänge, ja, also da haben sie alle, was sie brauchen. Und dann so, jetzt können sie ja mal eine Probefahrt machen. Und ich so, nee, nee, ist schon okay, ich nehm's so. Wie, sie müssen noch eine Probefahrt machen. Oh mein Gott. Nein, nein, ist okay, ich nehm's so, alles passt schon. Also, ihr könnt doch kein Fahrrad nehmen ohne eine Probe. Der war wirklich kurz davor, mir das Fahrrad nicht zu verkaufen. Weil du nicht genau gefragt hast. Genau, weil ich nicht in seinem Spiel mitgespielt habe. Er hat einfach gesagt, ich gebe ihnen den Preis. Aber das Interessante ist ja jetzt, du willst sozusagen so sehr diesen sozialen Interaktionen entfliehen, dass du jetzt wieder dir in den Schwanz,
die Katze beißt sich in den Schwanz. Die Katze im Sack
beißt sich im Sack in den
Schwanz. Denn
dadurch, dass du jetzt so sehr vor
sozialen Interaktionen fließt,
crasht du jetzt in eine neue rein.
Nämlich, dass du dich so sehr entfremdet hast
von dem Fahrradverkäufer,
dass er die Situation anspricht und
sagt, nee, du machst doch bitte jetzt, also
der es fast nicht wieder verkaufen will, weil
du diese Probefahrten nicht machst. Deswegen
Vielen Dank. von dem Fahrradverkäufer, dass er die Situation anspricht und sagt, nee, du machst doch bitte jetzt, also der es fast nicht wieder verkaufen will, weil du diese Probefahrten nicht machst. Deswegen read the room und du musst dich dann vielleicht Sozialchameleon ein bisschen anpassen und dann kommst du vielleicht einfacher durch, wenn du kurz die Bremse betätigst oder sowas. Du weißt nicht genau, was du erfüllen willst oder sowas. Kurze Anekdote, ich war mal in einem Flugzeugmuseum und da stand so ein Tarnkappenflugzeug.
Kennst du ja vielleicht, die diese Platten haben, die so in Winkeln sind. Ich habe noch nie ein Tarnkappenflugzeug gesehen. Kein Mensch weiß, wie das funktioniert. Das ist halt irgendwie, dass die Radarstrahlen da irgendwie abprallen und dann sieht man es nicht oder so. Und dann war ich in diesem Museum und ich habe gemerkt, die meisten Leute stehen um dieses Tarnkappenflugzeug rum und schauen sich das an. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist auch nicht die Idee der Sache. So, dass alle jetzt das Tarn, dass das nicht gesehen werden will, das wollen alle sehen, weil das das Besondere ist. Die anderen Flugzeuge normal langweilig, aber alle denken sich, boah, wie ist es? Und sowas bei mir in dem Moment auch. Dadurch, dass ich möglichst unsichtbar sein wollte, wurde ich sehr sichtbar, weil ich plötzlich auffalle als, oh, der hat jetzt anders. Genau. Bei dem funktioniert es jetzt anders. Richtig. Und da war dann das Problem. Aber ich wollte, das ist doch die grösste Faris, dann so eine Probefahrt zu machen. Das ist doch wieder der Friseurmoment, wo du aufs Fahrrad steigst und ich war eben, ich bin seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr Fahrrad gefahren. Ich würde so einfach draufsteigen und einfach seitlich umfallen und sagen, super, perfekt, passt, nehm ich. Also, ich werde jetzt auch nicht in der Innenstadt rumfahren. Genau, und du musst ja einen gewissen Radius probieren, weil, um auch die Gänge auszutesten. Dann ist aber die Frage, wie weit kannst du wegfahren, bis er denkt, du klaust das nachher noch, du fährst jetzt einfach weg, alles daran ist so doof es ist furchtbar, es ist furchtbar
Problem ist aber jetzt, du musst
ein bisschen sein Spiel mitspielen, sonst
ja, ich hab natürlich so Pseudo
mal so die Reifen gedrückt
ohne zu wissen, was man erwartet, aber ja
es hat Reifen, drücke ich da
und dann meint er noch so, ja ja, hier ist jetzt
so ein bisschen diese Verkleidung abgefallen
aber die kriegen sie ganz billig für 5 Euro
und die kann ich ihnen auch anmontieren, wenn sie eine haben
kein Problem und ich nur
Vielen Dank. Und dann meinte er noch so, ja, ja, hier ist jetzt so ein bisschen diese Verkleidung abgefallen, aber die kriegen sie ganz billig für fünf Euro und die kann ich ihnen auch anmontieren, wenn sie eine haben, kein Problem. Und ich nur, ich nehm's, ich nehm's, einfach nur ich nehm's. Und der war wirklich skeptisch, der war wirklich ein bisschen wütend. Also ich weiss nicht, ob er irgendwo dachte, du bist doch undercover hier, oder? Also ich meine, du bist doch, bist du von der Fahrradmafia oder ich weiss nicht, was.
Soko Fahrrad.
Er hat mir was unterstellt, seine Blicke waren unterstellend, ohne dass klar wurde was genau. Er meinte so, was spielst du hier für ein Spiel? Warum willst du nicht Probefahrt? Und ich wusste aber nicht genau, ich wusste nicht gegen welchen Vorwurf ich mich verteidigen muss. Und letztendlich habe ich gesagt, ich nehme es, ich nehme es, ich nehme es einfach, hier bitte, überreicht das Geld passend. Und er sagt, ah, 55 Euro reicht auch. Und du sagst, fuck this, das ist die Hölle. Und er einfach, ja passt, okay, danke. Und er will auch noch so hinterher so, ja schauen Sie mal, dass der, weil der Ständer ist, dass der nicht rostet. Ich will einfach nur hier weg, ich will einfach nur hier weg. Es war richtig furchtbar, es war worst case. es ist so, von Anfang an, vielleicht hätte ich auch schon bei der Nachricht über die Kleine schreiben sollen, ich möchte nicht verhandeln. Ich zahle den Preis. Lass uns diese Scharade einfach. Idee? Er war so drin in seinem Bazaar-Mode, in seinem Anpreisen und so und ich wollte einfach so direkt reingrätschen und sagen, stopp, wir müssen das nicht machen. Idee, wir machen sowas wie die Self-Checkout-Kasse bei Rewe. Ja. Nur machen das quasi, also wir entwickeln sozusagen so eine Storage-Unit. Ja. Oh, das wäre ein Traum. Das sind so Drop-Off-Kisten. So eine Packstation. Eine Packstation für Ebay. Ja. So, da ist genug Platz drin für, sagen wir mal, 20 Fahrräder, damit man sich jetzt gut vorstellen kann, wie viel Platz ich meine. So, und dann kann man da als Verkäufer
geht man da hin, stellt das rein,
gibt den Preis ein in so einem Tastenfeld,
den man dafür haben will, macht es zu
und dann... Ah, das ist wie so ein Automat.
Und man muss auch nicht, genau, man kann sich das
dann disposen, man kann da hingehen,
gibt dann, kannst die Karte dran halten,
das wird dann direkt überwiesen auf deinem
Konto und nur wenn du den richtigen Betrag
eingibst, geht es auf. Diese Maschine
verhandelt für dich, diese Maschine macht alles
Vielen Dank. dann kannst du die Karte dran halten, das wird dann direkt überwiesen auf deinem Konto und nur wenn du den richtigen Betrag eingibst, geht es auf. Diese Maschine verhandelt für dich, diese Maschine macht alles für dich, du musst mit keinem Menschen interagieren. Das wäre super. Wenn bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen es heißt, ich stelle es an die alte Mühle, ich stelle den Koffer an die alte Mühle, sie nehmen den Koffer, stellen das Fahrrad hin und ich hole das Fahrrad, fertig, kein Problem. Das wäre einfach grossartig. Übrigens, wo ich auch nachgedacht habe, weil es ist ja oft so, also du gehst auf Überkleinzeigen und es ist klar, die meisten Fahrräder sind einfach geklaut, aber geklaut. Es gibt einfach Accounts, die haben einfach, die verkaufen 50 gebrauchte Fahrräder und das ist einfach eine Privatperson und jeder Beschreibungstext ist exakt gleich, also es ist nicht irgendwie ein Fahrradverkäufer, der da irgendwie Arbeit reinsteckt. Das würde ich auch genauso machen, wenn ich ein Fahrradverkäufer wäre, würde ich einfach den gleichen Text immer reinschreiben. Dass du immer schreibst hier keine Probleme. Das ist meine Faulheit, nicht kriminelle Energie. Na, ich weiß nicht, du würdest schon eine Modellnummer oder irgendwie sowas. Und man denkt, okay, die sind einfach geklaut. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Deal so, wenn dein Fahrrad geklaut wird. Eigentlich müsste man nicht Fahrraddieb sein, sondern Fahrradentführer. Dass du das Fahrrad klaust, aber du hängst einen Zettel hin und sagst, überweisen Sie 100, von mir aus auch irgendwie Kryptokram, dass es nicht irgendwie zurückverfolgt werden kann, überweisen Sie 100 Euro an die Nummer und morgen steht ihr Fahrrad wieder hier.
Das ist ja wunderbar, können wir es doch abkürzen. Das finde ich super, das habe ich nämlich neulich gesehen in irgendeiner holländischen Stadt, irgendwie Utrecht oder sowas, so eine richtige Studentenfahrradstadt, auch so typische, wie man das kennt, aus den Bildern im Internet, einfach eine Landschaft aus Fahrrädern. Und da wird aber auch immer, werden Fahrräder immer geklaut. Und es gibt aber Hotspots, wo die dann wieder verkauft werden. Und man kennt diese Hotspots auch, wenn man da groß geworden ist und so. Das heißt, du hast dann immer einen Zehner dabei, gehst dann dahin und kaufst dein Fahrrad zurück. Es passiert also, irgendwie hat sich dann so ein sehr entspanntes System, wo man nicht wirklich sauer auf den Dieb ist. Es ist so ein bisschen ein Teil. Es ist so wie so ein Abo. Du zahlst halt zehn Euro im Monat und dafür hast du keine Fahrrad. Ja, ein bisschen so Mafios-Schutzgeld mässig. Ja, hier ist dein Fahrrad zurück Geld und es ist so wie so ein Steuer, Fahrradsteuer. Und es ist inzwischen akzeptiert. Du gehst dann zu dem Dieb hin, man grüsst sich, moin moin und dann gibt man die Zähne ab und dann zieht dein Fahrrad zurück. Und er so, ah, ich habe es für Sie schon reserviert, ja wunderbar, dass kein anderes kauft, sondern man kauft es direkt zurück. Ne genau, wir kennen uns ja, inzwischen kennt man sich ja auch und man will das aber, man merkt es nicht böse, es ist einfach da sein Job. Anstatt dass Sie das ständig klauen müssen, ich kann Ihnen das am Montag einfach vorbeibringen. Ich bringe Ihnen am Montag einfach
mein Fahrrad vorbei und dann hole ich es am Dienstag ab zu 10 Euro.
Dann können wir das doch einfach überspringen und Sie überweisen mir einfach 10 Euro
monatlich. 10 Euro im Monat? Ja, wunderbar,
dann machen wir es doch so. Perfekt. Ist doch super.
Weil Sie so ein guter Kunde sind, wir machen 8 Euro im Monat.
Perfekt? Ja, wunderbar. Dankeschön.
Vielen Dank. Dann freut es mich auch.
Tschüss. Ciao, ciao. Vergessen Sie das Fahrrad nicht.
Ja, nein. Schönen Tag.
Es wäre viel angenehmer. Schön, wenn dann noch so eine Gummibärchen-Tüte hinten auf dem Sattel ist. Oh, das ist auch nett. Das ist ja ein Konkurrenzkampf. Es gibt ja auch viele Diebe in Amsterdam und du musst dann gucken, bei wem du dann das immer abholst, von wem du bestohlen werden willst. Mein Dieb ist ein Fünf-Sterne-Dieb, wirklich. Aber du hast eigentlich recht, im Grunde ist das Mafia, also die Androhung von einer Straftat reicht, um Geld auszupressen, aber man kann zusammen leben. Ich find's toll. Ich find's super. Das ist so Next-Level-Leben, Gesellschaft. Die haben es so hingekriegt, dass man selbst mit den Kriminellen irgendwie so mega freundschaftlich nebeneinander koexistiert. Ich glaube, jedes Abo-Modell wird langfristig so dieses Einzelkaufmodell ablösen. Für alles. Also irgendwann hast du auch eine Supermarkt-Flatrate, eine Gemüse-Flatrate, wo du halt einfach dann, sagen wir mal, so und so viel kaufen kannst und es ist alles kostenlos. Du hast eine Kriminalitäts-Flatrate, Bahn, halt irgendwie alles irgendwie x Euro im Jahr. Was ich einführen will, ist Friseur, dass man, keine Ahnung, dass man einen Friseur monatlichen Bet Betrag zahlt und dann kann man immer hingehen, wenn man will. Okay. Die meisten gehen ja eh nur einmal hin, aber angenommen, du hast dann mal irgendwie ein Date oder sowas, muss mal richtig gut aussehen oder hast einen Live-Auftritt, keine Ahnung, in Hannover oder so. Gerade wenn ich ein Date hätte, würde ich nicht zum Friseur gehen. Ach ja, du bist da anders. Wenn ich ein Date hätte, würde ich versuchen, so eine Woche davor. Ja klar, das ist die Königsdisziplin, wenn das geht. Also Plansterror wirklich. Was ist ein guter Zeitraum zwischen erstem und zweiten Date? Oder zwischen Treffen, also was ist die maximale Distanz, die du sagst, hey, wollen wir uns in vier Wochen treffen? Ist zu viel. Aber wenn du sagst, keine Ahnung, jetzt irgendwie, sagen wir mal so Kollegin oder Freundin, Freund des Freundes oder irgendwie so diese klassischen Kennenlernszenarios, was ist ein guter Zeitraum, wo du sagst, lass uns in drei Tagen treffen oder was ist morgen direkt? Ich bin klassischer am Wochenrhythmus. Am Wochenende dann? Nee, Wochenende nicht. In einer Woche? Oh, Wochenende, Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Puh, nein. Du sagst in einer Woche? Immer donnerstags. Donnerstags ist ein guter Date-Night, nur dienstags. Nein, Stefan, Date-Night. Dienstags und Donnerstag sind ein guter Date-Night. Also angenommen, wir treffen uns jetzt am Freitag. Wir sind auf einer Party, ich bin ein Kumpel von Hugo und wir treffen uns auf einer Party und zwischen uns es funkt, es funktioniert und wir sind kurz davor zu abschieben. Ciao Hugo, alles klar, ich würde dann hier es packen, ne? Okay, du willst es dann hier jetzt packen, im Sinne von du willst es gehen oder was? Ja genau. Achso, ja, okay. Wollen wir uns vielleicht, die Kalender rausholen und ein bisschen, lass mal kurz die Kalender übereinander legen. Ja, ich hab eigentlich Zeit, immer. Ja, immer? Immer. Okay, wie wär's mit Donnerstag Nacht? In sechs Tagen. Ja. Oder Dienstag, wenn es dir eher passt. Okay, ich find sechs Tage ist ein bisschen arg lang, oder nicht? Arg lang? Nee, sechs Tage jetzt irgendwie.
Also wollen wir uns treffen oder nicht?
Können wir gerne machen.
Okay, gut.
Ich biete zwei Tage zur Auswahl, Dienstag oder Donnerstag, wie es dir passt.
Ja, Dienstag habe ich Fechten.
Ah ja, gut, ich habe auch als Pilates.
Ja.
Nennst du Donnerstag?
Gegenfechten oder?
Nee, mit so japanischen Schwertern. Katanas. Cool, cool, cool. Dann Donnerstag. Alles klar, packst du es jetzt? Ich pack es jetzt, jetzt wird gepackt. Ich finde sechs Tage ein bisschen lang. Ich nicht, ich finde es okay. Aber dann kannst du ja noch zum Friseur gehen und fünf Tage beten, hoffen, dass es noch nötig wächst einfach.
Ich finde Wochenende beim ersten Date nicht gut. Da hast du halt Open-End-Zeit und dann muss man schon, wenn es nicht so gut laufen könnte, muss man halt einen Abflug schaffen. Den muss man aber konstruieren, das ist nicht so einfach, weil du kannst am Wochenende schlechter sagen, ich muss morgen früh raus. Es ist auch nicht so sozial akzeptiert, dann zum Beispiel schon um zehn Uhr es zu packen, weil es halt ein Freitagnacht oder Samstagnacht, da hast du halt theoretisch Zeit, da ist man unterwegs. Zehn Uhr ist schon nicht, ich finde es, ich bin auch nicht mehr in dem Alter, zwölf, zehn Uhr ist schon spät, da würde ich jetzt langsam schon an das Zähneputzen denken. Dast du an Zähneputzen und die Augen werden schon ganz klein. Aber nee, also deswegen kann ich nur für das erste Date auf jeden Fall Dienstag empfehlen. Wenn es dann sehr gut läuft, kann man sich dann direkt für zum Beispiel Sonntag verabreden oder sowas. Okay. Sonntag mag ich auch gerne als Date Night. Sonntag, weil du kannst sagen, ich muss morgen früh raus. Nein, kann sagen. Ich mag, dass du es immer planst, so dass du eine gute Exit-Strategie hast, dass du immer raus kannst.
Ja, Exit ist immer früh raus. Es werden auch die lächerlichsten Arbeitszeiten und Dinge erfunden.
Was natürlich einfach ist als Freelancer, kann man immer mal sagen, nee, ich habe gleich noch um elf Uhr noch einen Call.
Um elf Uhr? Ja, also ich habe noch, ja, ist halt mit Zeitverschiebung, mit L.A.
Pff, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha Holy shit, macht dich mega spannend, unfassbar arrogant, aber es ist, ja, okay, ganz einfach sagen, dass ich gehen soll.
Ne, ich habe noch ein Call mit L.A. Ja, okay, zeig mir deinen Google-Eintrag, zeig mir deinen Kalendereintrag, wer es jetzt noch ein Call hat mit L.A.
Den habe ich vorbereitet. Der ist ein Call mit L.A.
So ein sehr vager
mit Lukas Andrachs.
Ja, ist schwierig. Aber finde ich
einen guten Zeitraum auf jeden Fall.
Oder Fahrraddate.
Fahrradtour. Kann ich jetzt auch machen.
Schön jetzt irgendwie.
Ich meine, das Problem an dem Fahrrad ist,
es hat ein Dynamo und ich bin auch nachts gefahren und dachte mir, geil, Dynamo, perfekt, schnall den Dynamo ran, bin unterwegs, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, wuh, aber kein Licht. Ah, okay, cool. Das ist ein Geräusch-Dynamo. Das Fahrrad hat ein Dynamo, also es hat ein Kraftwerk, aber, und da dachte ich mir, wo geht das jetzt alles hin? Diese enormen Energieleistungen, diese enormen, also da war wirklich auch, das war ein hoher Ton, da war enorme Energie im Spiel, die aber einfach auf die Strasse rausgelaufen ist. Ich hatte mal eins, wo dann die Energie in den Rahmen selber geschleitet wurde, und immer wenn ich dann gebremst habe oder die Klingel angefasst habe, habe ich einen gewischt bekommen. Ach geil. Da ging die ganze Dynamo-Energie hin, das war extrem und ich immer aufgezuckt bin. Aber ich bin gegen Fahrraddates, weil es ist so schwierig, den Idealabstand zu haben, dass man noch miteinander reden kann. Das ist so wie beim Reiten, wie bei Red Dead Redemption. Da gibt es ja auch so einen Knopf, dass du dich automatisch synchronisierst und nebeneinander reitest. Ah ja, okay. Und sowas bräuchte man Ja, gibt es aber nicht und dann fährt man hintereinander und dann schreibt man immer und dann Ja, oder halt Tandem. Ja, super. Wer sitzt vorne, wer sitzt hinten? Oder kannst du nicht ein Tandem machen, wo sich die Leute angucken? Wie diese Bierbikes. Wo halt dann der hinten steuert und muss dann immer so an der Person vorbeigucken, um zu lenken, aber man kann sich trotzdem noch gut unterhalten. Und die andere Person hat einfach Todesangst, die gesamte Zeit. Ja, die ganze Zeit. Rückwärtsferd. Sehr gut. Aber man kann sich schön unterhalten. Ich meine, du kennst mich ja, ich bin ja ein humoristischer Mensch und hab natürlich beim Thema Fahrrad auch so ein bisschen daran gedacht, soll ich mir nicht ein richtig dummes Fahrrad kaufen? Mit so einer Fahne hinten dran. Mit so einer Fahne, man denkt natürlich erstmal an Tandem, Tandem alleine fahren finde ich einfach saulustig. Aber es ist natürlich schon dumm, wenn man eine halbe Stunde zur Arbeit fahren muss. Und dann dachte ich mir auch so, es gibt ja manchmal so Fahrräder, die so einen grossen Kasten vorne haben, so mit zwei Rädern links und rechts. So ein Lastenrad. Nein, nicht so ein Lastenrad. Schon, das ist ja so länger, es hat eigentlich die gleiche Distanz, nur vorne ist dann noch so wie Eis oder so, wo man Eis draus verkaufen kann oder so. Und das ohne, ohne dass ich's brauche, hätte ich auch lustig gefunden.
Aber ich dachte mir dann,
was ist mir Humor wert, was ist mir
ein Lächeln wert?
Vor allem, was man auch beim Fahrrad nicht
unterschätzen darf, ist, dass man ab und zu
auf Kopfsteinpflaster kommt.
Und wenn man währenddessen redet.
Das ist immer unangenehm, weil stell dir mal vor, du fängst
irgendwie ein ernstes Thema an und sagst, ja, dann haben sich meine Eltern
schon bei Eltern, und dann war das ein bisschen ein Problem, weil das Kind hat das schon, Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein ein ernstes Thema an und sagst, ja dann haben sich meine Eltern schon bei Eltern, das war ein bisschen ein Problem, weil das Kind hat ja schon alleine. Und dann bist du halt auf so einem Kopfsteinplaster. Das heißt, und sie will auch nicht, kannst du noch mal sagen mit deinem, also ich habe nur Trauma verstanden, traumatisches was? Ja genau, man will den ersten Move machen, irgendwie so, man will flirten und dann kommt man aber auf Kopfsteinaster und ist dann so, du hast mir wirklich schöne Augen. Und es macht nicht cool. Das ist richtig unangenehm. Du musst im Vorhinein aber die Route genau wissen, wo ist Kopfsteinpflaster, wo nicht, wo sind dann auch mal so die Phasen, wo man vielleicht mal eher zuhört. Das ist schon schwierig. Damit weil sie dann auf Kopfsteinpflaster ist. Da muss man eine Frage stellen. Das ist dann so ein Quicktime-Event, wo du im richtigen Moment X drücken musst,
wo du ihr eine Frage stellst, bevor Kopfsteinpflaster kommt.
Ich verstehe deine Gaming-Referenznehmer nicht.
Tja.
Okay.
Du willst es mir auch nicht erklären.
Okay, alles klar. Nein, nein, nein.
Ich drücke einfach im richtigen Moment auf X und guck mal,
was passiert.
Aber apropos, du hast ja,
ich hab mich vielleicht ein bisschen anstecken lassen von dir letzte Woche.
Oh. Weil du hast ja letzte Woche unsere Community zu Pranks aufgerufen. Ja. Zum Glück hat es niemand gemacht. Nee, das war ja auch die Idee. Du bist nicht enttäuscht. Ich bin nicht enttäuscht, nee, es war ja, es war ein gemeiner Prank, ich wollte, dass Leute, ich erinnere mich zum ersten Mal an der Geschichte des Podcast-Projektes, das, was ich gesagt habe, ich wollte, dass Leute Menschen bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, die Spiegel verkaufen, anschreiben, ob sie ein besseres Foto vom Spiegel haben, weil die Theorie ist, dass die eh schon genervt waren von dem ganzen Fotomachprozess des Spiegels. Das solltet ihr natürlich nicht machen, das war alles for the gag and for the gag only. Was ist mir ein Lachen wert, das bis dahin. Wir können allerdings den Twitter-Account Selling a Mirror empfehlen. People, yes, yes. People Selling Mirrors, er heißt At Selling a Mirror, wo sämtliche Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, Verkaufsportale, Bilder gesammelt werden, wo Leute ihren Spiel verkaufen und den ja irgendwie fotografieren müssen und dann zwangsläufig entweder sich selbst oder ihr unaufgeräumtes Zimmer oder ein Hund oder was auch immer zeigen. Und das ist grossartig, es macht sehr viel Spaß, weil es gibt verschiedene Kategorien. Es gibt einmal den sehr Selbstbewussten, der sich einfach selber fotografiert. Dann gibt es den, der versteckt sein will oder zum Beispiel sich ein Tuch über den Kopf legt oder sich die Augen zuhält, um irgendwie inkognitur zu sein. Dann gibt es die, die absichtlich irgendwie was anderes im Spiegel fotografieren. Ist ein toller Account, könnt ihr euch gerne anschauen, macht viel Spaß. Oh, hier ist einer wahnsinnig selbstbewusst, oberkörperfrei. Das ist natürlich wahnsinnig weird. Jesus Christ. Vor allem, ich glaube, es gibt ja diese Tanzspiegel, wo die ganze Wand verspiegelt ist, und das kannst du nicht verstecken. People Selling Mirrors ist ja absolut fantastisch. Es ist wirklich ein fantastischer Account. Man muss sich echt, man muss sich, vor allem diese Stimmung, in der man ist, wenn man Dinge bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen reinstellt, ist nicht dafür gemacht, auf dem Foto zu sein. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Man ist nicht, man hat diese typische, diese Sonntagsschlafanzugsachen an, verwuschelte Haare, ganz kleine Augen, dicke Augenringe, das ist die Stimmung, in der man ist, wenn man bei Ebay Sachen reinstellt. Aber der Spiegel, alle beziehen sich schön an. Das ist so lustig, man muss sich, you have to dress up, wenn du bei Ebay Spiegel reinstellst, weil man sieht dich. Gott, ist das lustig. Selling people selling mirrors. Ich glaube, das ist mein Favorit. Der so fotografiert und sein Körper ist klein und darüber ist sein Kopf in riesengroß. Fantastisch. Aber ich glaube, also tatsächlich hat niemand deine Prank-Idee aufgegriffen, worüber ich sehr dankbar bin. Aber ich war, glaube ich, dadurch angesteckt von dir und ich war irgendwie im Prank-Modus ein bisschen. Und tatsächlich dachte ich, ich wurde geprankt. Ich dachte, ich wurde geprankt.
Ich habe nämlich auf WhatsApp von einer random Nummer die Nachricht bekommen,
hallo, sind Sie Herr Stephan?
Ah, ah.
Da dachte ich schon, okay, der prankt jetzt irgendein Podcast-Ufo-Hörer,
hat irgendwie meine Nummer rausgekriegt, irgendwie über Kontakte oder was auch immer, ha ha ha.
Hallo, sind Sie Herr Stephan?
Meine Tante gab mir ihren Kontakt und sagte mir, dass sie chinesischen Hotpot machen können. Auf welchem Level bist du? Puh, okay. Das erinnert mich an diese Fragen, die man stellt, die Hypnotiseure verwenden, um Leute so rauszuwerfen, dass sie dann irgendwie so einen Griff machen und dann ist man ohnmächtig. Genau, oder so die Fragen, die man so Schläferagenten, die seit fünf Jahren in der Land leben und dann aktiviert werden müssten und dann so, welches Level bist du?
Also, diese Person schreibt, jemand hat mir gesagt, dass sie chinesischen Hotpot machen können, auf welchem Level bist du?
Das ist wirklich diese Pranks, wenn man Leute, die schlafen, aufweckt und dann stellt man den Fragen wie Florentin, kannst du Holz auf dem Mond ein Baum sein? Für fünf. Ja genau, und dann wachten die Leute auf und geben dann ernste Antworten auch darauf, weil es halt so in so einem Traummechanismus irgendwie dann Sinn ergibt oder sowas. Das Menschliche hier funktioniert ja irgendwie. Es ist super verwirrend. Aber es ist natürlich auf welchem Level. Wir gehen da mal ruhig, wir gehen da mal jetzt ruhig durch. Auf welchem Level bist du? Und ich antworte Level drei. Für chinesische Hotpots. Chinesische Hotpot-Level, Level drei, würde ich sagen. Und wenn die Person fragt, sind Sie Küchenchef Herr Stefan aus Berlin? Das ist eine sehr konkrete Frage, ehrlich gesagt. Und da war ich mir jetzt nicht mehr so sicher, ob ich hier geprankt werde. Sind sie Küchen-, also weil du ja schon immer so ein bisschen betonst, dass du gut kochen kannst. Ich kann gar nicht gut kochen. Küchenchef Herr Stephan. Das ist ja lustig. Also verwirrend vor allen Dingen. Ich glaube, da wurde es nicht geprankt. Ich glaube, das ist, ähm... Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es nicht. Ich habe dann vielleicht auch eine falsche Abbiegung genommen. Ich habe geantwortet,
sie sind noch nicht bereit für die Geheimnisse des Hotpot, sie sind noch nicht mal Level zwei.
Person schreibt, meine Tante hat mir erzählt, dass sie schon von, dass ich, dass sie dir schon
von meinem Restaurant erzählt hat. Ich schreibe, welchen Level hat ihre Tante?
Es kippt langsam, du verarschst einfach eine Person, die vielleicht nicht so gut Deutsch spricht
und immer mit dem Übersetzer benutzt und du bist einfach ein Arschloch-Deutscher.
Und dann schreibt die Person nur noch, sie sind nicht Herr Stefan.
Ende. Ende.
Ende. Florentinsprank. Ja, es hat nicht so... Wow. Vor allem, ich dachte ja erst, ich werde geprankt und wollte zurückpranken, aber stellt sich raus, es gab nie einen Prank. Ihr seid heute Abend hier zusammengekommen, damit ich euch eure neuen Level nenne. Wir alle sind in diesem Hotpot-Kurs seit nun fünfzehn Jahren. Meister Florentin, bitte, tritt hervor. Vielen Dank, Sensei. Dein Hot Pot ist gut. Danke. Keine Frage. Die Zutaten, die Temperatur, die Dauer, alles gut, es würzig. Wollen Sie da rangehen, Sensei? Nee, ich lasse es kurz klingen. Es würzig.
Er ist frisch.
Er hat eine gewisse Schärfe.
Nicht so scharf.
Europäisch scharf.
Wir mögen das.
Aber ihm fehlt das gewisse etwas.
Da arbeiten wir jetzt schon länger dran und entwickeln sich nicht weiter. Dein Level, Meister Florentin, ist die drei. Hugo, dein Hotpot ist fantastisch, er ist super, nicht so wie Florentins, mittelmässig. Florentins Hotpot hat einfach Schwächen. Ja. Hugo, dein Level ist sieben. Sieben? Florentin, hast du was dazu zu sagen? Es gibt 19 Level. Drei von 19 bin ich. Drei von 19. Haben Sie eine Ahnung, wie heiß mein Hotpot ist? Superheiß. Aber es geht ja nicht nur um die Temperatur, aber ein Hotpot. Ist ein Hotpot? Ja, klar, es heißt Hotpot. Aber es geht auch um den Pot. Was ist denn ein Pot? Vielleicht habe ich doch noch viel zu leer. Wollen wir den Hotpot-Cast machen? Finde ich eine gute Idee, aber ich meine, das passt ja auch so ein bisschen. Also ich meine, das gibt es ja auch so bei Karate oder so, gibt es ja auch diese Gürtel. Also vielleicht ist es tatsächlich auch in der asiatischen Kultur dieses Level-System oder dieses Ebenensystem, dass es auch beim Wochen gibt. Wie farbige Gürtel gibt es, wie farbige Löffel oder so. Irgendwie sowas Oder, dass man sich da so hocharbeiten muss, Stück für Stück. Das sind blau-grünen Löffel. Das kann schon sein. Kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Es gibt ja tatsächlich in der Gastronomie sowas, also verschiedene Stufen. Also gerade bei den, ja genau, aber auch bei den Sommeliers zum Beispiel gibt es halt die Normal-ass-HK geprüften Sommeliers und dann gibt es noch die Master-Sommeliers. Da könnte ich eine ganz tolle Doku empfehlen auf Amazon. Somm heisst die S-O-M-M über so drei Amis, die bereits Sommeliers sind. Auch, ich glaube, ganz gut verdienende Sommeliers in coolen Restaurants. Aber die wollen Master-Sommeliers werden. Es gibt nicht so viele Master-Sommeliers auf der Welt, es sind ein paar hundert nur. Und du musst wirklich irgendwie aus, keine Ahnung, selbst die slowenischen Weingebiete musst du alle kennen, weil du kriegst dann bei der Prüfung, gibt es halt eine theoretische Prüfung, die, glaube ich, mit zu den schwersten auf der ganzen Welt zählt, für alle übergreifend, Tests der Welt und dann hast du halt sechs Weine kriegst du noch, drei rot, drei weiss, musst die erschmecken, muss sogar ja, am liebsten noch so den Hang, aber muss vor allem das Weingebiet sagen. Wer hat die Trauben gepflückt, wer hat da gestampft und was war die Temperatur am Tag, am Tag vor der Pflückung. Krass. Nee, aber du musst wirklich viel wissen, du musst es erschmecken und so und das kriegen nicht so viele hin. Und das ist spannend. Und da gibt es halt auch wirklich dann, krie kriege ich so ein kleines Abzeichen, da gibt es so eine rote Schleife oder sowas für den Mars, also Mellier, die tragen dann rot. Wäre das was für dich? Ich glaube schon, also ich mag halt keinen Wein. Nee, aber das ist ja egal. Also ich wäre dann vielleicht so, sagen wir mal so Chocoban Sommelier oder sowas, also ich kann dir genau sagen, kommt es aus einer 400-Gramm-Packung, 200-Gramm-Packung. Das glaube ich, könnte ich auch. Stand es in der Sonne oder nicht? So welches Jahr ungefähr? Also welche Nussernte, das kann ich dir dann schon sagen. Interessiert halt nur niemanden, weil es halt das, was da ist. Selbst ein schlechtes Chocoban ist noch gut. Nein, finde ich nicht. Was? Ich finde, Chocoban haben riesige Schwankungen. Wirklich? Unangenehm grosse Schwankungen. Nein, Quatsch. Bei Kinderriegeln zum Beispiel ungesehen. Die schmecken immer gleich. Pinguie immer gleich. Milchschnitte immer gleich. Alles schmeckt immer gleich. Aber meinst du jetzt einfach unterschiedliche Temperaturen, wenn die zu warm oder kalt sind? Schokobons schmecken so unterschiedlich? Innerhalb einer Packung? Kinder Bueno auch. Nee, innerhalb einer Packung glaube ich nicht. Okay, aber es gibt auch Jahrgänge. Was ist der beste Jahrgang für dich im Schokobon? 98. 98? Gibt es da noch welche? Nach wie vor so gut, wirklich. 98 Schokobons. Wo ich immer finde, dass es große Schwankungen gibt, sind diese Fruchtnummern, so Fred Ferkel oder so. Fred Ferkel sind teilweise wirklich hauchzart, weich, anschmiegsam
und manchmal einfach richtig hart.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, woran es liegt, aber da
ist es ja wirklich, Temperatur meinst du?
Ich glaube auch, wie alt die sind.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Aber das
ist so ein Ding, da habe ich wirklich schon
Überraschungen erlebt, wohingegen bei Chocomont
war ich immer zufrieden eigentlich.
Du warst immer zufrieden? Immer zufrieden. Aber du hast mal gesagt, du riechst nicht gut. Ich riech überhaupt nicht gut. Ja, aber dann schmeckst du auch nicht gut. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, aber dann brauchen wir... Ja, deswegen esse ich ja auch nur Schrottessen, aber bin trotzdem zufrieden. Aber dann reden wir viel zu häufig über Essen dafür, dass du gar nichts schmeckst, dass du einfach... Ich bin, ein Blinder redet auch nicht die ganze Zeit davon, was er sieht, so. Ne? Ja. Vielleicht ist es die besondere Herausforderung, die mich kickt. Aber sind deswegen andere Sinne bei dir geschärfter? Ne. Habe ich mir letztens auch gedacht, weil es ist ja oft so, dass man sich da auf andere Sinne verlässt. Vielleicht habe ich ein gutes Gehör. Aber eigentlich auch nicht, weil ich halt immer irgendwelche Kameras in den Ohren stecken habe. Das kompensiert das Ganze wieder so ein bisschen. Fühlst du gut? Vielleicht fühle ich sehr gut. Das wäre zu bewerten. Ja, ich versuche immer zu fühlen, wenn ich jetzt mit dem Finger meine Hand berühre. Spüre ich die Berührung am Finger oder an der Hand? Damit kann ich Stunden verbringen. Dann fühlst du auch nicht gut, glaube ich. Ich glaube, deine Sinne sind, du bist ein sehr zauber Mensch. Weil ich denke mir auch so, angenommen, du berührst jetzt mit deiner Nase deinen Fuss, nicht leicht, aber du berührst mit der Nase den Fuss, dann ist ja die Distanz von Nase zu Gehirn wesentlich geringer als die von Fuss zu Gehirn. Also gibt es so eine Art, ich spüre eins zuerst und ich glaube erst wenn man das, also das sind die Fülliers, erst wenn du das fühlen kannst, den Unterschied sozusagen so, ne ne, so zwei Impulse direkt hintereinander, dann glaube ich, kannst du richtig gut fühlen, davor müssen wir gar nicht kommen mit, ich kann gut fühlen.
Es gibt ein übergeordnetes Auge, das ist auch spannend. Ein Auge setzt sich durch über das andere. Das habe ich bei dem ganzen Augenlaser-Ding gecheckt, haben die mir dann erklärt, es gibt ein Auge, und bei mir war es halt das Schwächere, ein bisschen dusselig, aber du hast ja gewisse Dinge, die sich überschreiben, das sind zwei Sichtfelder der beiden Augen, und in der Mitte hast du halt, ne hängt zusammen, deswegen der 3D-Effekt, aber du hast ja sehr viel, was gemeinsam abgedeckt wird. Ja. Und wenn du ein Auge abdeckst, siehst du genau, ich weiss nicht mehr genau, wie der Test ging, aber du merkst, eins überschreibt das andere.
Ach so. Das heißt, eins ist wichtiger, weil quasi das ist ja die Frage bei Adobe, Photoshop, welche Ebene ist höher, die rechte und die links, eine Ebene ist drüber auf jeden Fall. Und wie einigen die sich? Also die sagen so, ah, hi, übrigens, hi, Carl, hi, Lefty, hi, wie sind die beiden Augen, oder was? Carl, ich bin Carl, ja.
Okay, ich bin Lefty wegen links, verstehe ich, okay.
Okay, also ich glaube, wir verstehen uns gut, es wird eine gute Zusammenarbeit und ich glaube, wenn einfach jeder seinen Teil macht der Arbeit.
Ja, ich habe es immer, genau, ich würde es einfach machen wie immer, ich war immer das Hauptauge und fände es auch nicht gut, wenn es so rein ist.
Ach so, ich fände es irgendwie besser, wenn wir das irgendwie nicht so machen mit Hauptauge, Nebenauge.
Sondern einfach jeder Fifty-Fifty und irgendwie jeder hat seinen Platz in den Augenhöhlen.
Und ich glaube, wenn wir da einfach offen zusammenarbeiten, ist das eigentlich auch cool, oder?
Klar, offen zusammenarbeiten finde ich mega geil. Ich würde einfach das Hauptauge sein, weil das haben wir immer so gemacht.
Ja, aber ich will gesagt, ich kenne dich jetzt halt auch nicht so gut und es fällt mir jetzt schwer, irgendwie da dir zu folgen, wenn ich nicht weiß.
Also ich meine zum Beispiel, was ist das da hinten?
Ich bin 28.
Was ist denn das da hinten?
Baum.
Nee, aber im Baum.
Aber Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne dich jetzt auch noch nicht so gut. Es fällt mir schwer, dir irgendwie zu folgen, wenn ich nicht weiss. Ich meine zum Beispiel, was ist das dahinten? Ich bin 28 Baum. Nee, aber im Baum. Äh, Gestalt, eine kleine orangene Gestalt, die sich bewegt. Weiss ich nicht. Na ja, guck mal, aber so, also ... Das war schon nicht schlecht. Ja. Aber weisst du, glaubst du nicht, dass wenn wir zusammenarbeiten ... Dass wir da weiterkommen, als wenn du jetzt ... Weil ich meine, warum soll ich meine, wir sind identisch. Was? Weiß ich nicht, ob wir identisch sind. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir identisch sind. Ja, aber was ist denn anders an dir? Ich bin woanders gelegen. Ich habe eine andere Vergangenheit vielleicht gehabt. Wir haben exakt dieselben Sachen gesehen. Ich sag nur, du hast einmal rechts, du hast einmal behauptet, Bigfoot ganz rechts an der Peripherie gesehen zu haben. Und ich hatte mal diese, bei der Migräne hatte ich mal so eine Aura. Ja, das stimmt. Und du siehst immer diese kleinen Würmchen da in der Luft. Oh, und einmal hat er diesen Test gemacht mit dem Finger und dann haben wir beide in die Mitte geguckt. Ja, das war geil. Das war so geil. Ach ja, das war eine gute Zeit. Nee, genau, deswegen würde ich einfach dich überschreiben.
Ja gut, aber dann lege ich mich hin.
Wenn du sagst, du bist der Chef, dann lege ich mich hin.
Kannst du gerne machen.
Okay, ja gut. Ein paar Urlaubstage vertreibe ich.
Alles klar, wenn wir es so machen, dann ... Okay, muss das so pikiert sein.
Dann würde ich mich hinlegen.
Und so schielt man dann.
Weil die Augen sich
verstritten haben. Schielen heißt, die Augen haben sich verstritten. Die schauen sich nicht mehr an, die reden nicht mehr miteinander. Die reden nicht mehr miteinander, die haben sich verstritten, die haben sich nicht mehr lieb. Und dann gucken die in verschiedene Richtungen. Aber das ist ja spannend, wenn die Nase den Fuss berührt, ich bin immer noch da, was fühlt man dann eher? Das ist die Frage, gibt es einen dominanten Fuss, gibt es eine dominante Nase oder sowas? Es ist erstaunlich, wie wenig wir fühlen. Aber ich glaube, es ist, Fühlen ist ja glaube ich eine der, na gut, alle Sinne müssen auch mal ausgeschaltet werden, aber zum Beispiel, du fühlst, dass du jetzt gerade einen Pulli anhast, du fühlst, dass du irgendwie eine Hose anhast, Schuhe, das wird alles so scheißegal, das ist alles so Spam-Mail im Gehirn so, Oh, Achtung, Fuss meldet Socken, Fuss meldet Socken, Fuss meldet Socken. Jesus, mach den aus, mach den aus. Ich hab dir gesagt, mach den aus. Ja, wir haben Socken an, okay, wir haben es verstanden. Mein Gott, Bein meldet Hose, Bein meldet Hose, Bein meldet Hose. Ich habe es verstanden langsam. Ich würde mich beschweren über die Arbeitsbedingungen hier. Was hier. Ich würde mich wirklich beschweren über die Arbeitsbedingungen hier. Was ist denn los? Ich bin halt nun mal ein kleiner Nervenende am Fuss. So, und da haben wir Socken an und ich mach nur meinen Job, okay? Ja, aber es geht nicht um dich, es interessiert keinen. Sorry, wenn irgendwas Besonderes passiert, wenn du irgendwo in den Nagel trittst oder so, reden wir nochmal drüber. Aber es ist scheißegal, niemand interessiert sich für die Füsse. Genau, das ist so. Und deswegen möchte ich gerne mit ihm vorgesetzt sprechen. Das ist doch jetzt albern. Nein, das ist gemein. Das ist gemein, das ist Mobbing. Das ist Mobbing am Arbeitsplatz. Ich kann auch nicht dafür, dass ich da unten bin. Wenn ich hier jeden Mitarbeiter, der hier ankommt, durchlassen würde zum Chef, dann hätten wir hier nur noch Tovabo den ganzen Tag. Was ist der? Bringt doch mal was Interessantes von den Füssen, hä, überlegt euch doch mal was da unten, ihr seid doch kreative Jungs und Mädels da unten, macht doch mal was Interessantes da unten, dass man wirklich was hat, wo man mal wirklich was melden kann. Es ist die ganze Zeit dunkel, es stinkt, es riecht käsig, er wäscht sich die nie, selbst beim Duschen wäscht er sich die Füsse nie. Ja, aber dann guck doch mal, wenn da mal irgendwas ist,
eine Glasscherbe oder sowas, ja, brainstorm,
dann macht er einfach mal outside the box, wenn da mal was passiert.
Ja, naja, Sand in der Socke, ja, guck doch mal, Sand in der Socke.
Steinchen, Steinchen, perfekt, wunderbar, Steinchen im Schuh,
wenn da was ist, komm an, liefer mir eine gute Story,
dann kommt sie auch zum Chef, okay?
Okay, ja, okay.
Da muss ein besserer Content kommen.
Sag nicht mehr, dass wir Spam sind. Okay, alles klar. Socke, Socke, Socke! Oh Gott, hau ab! Man fühlt, ja, ich, man ist, man könnte so viel fühlen, wenn man wölte, aber man wölte nicht. Man wölte ja nicht. Man wölte nicht, wenn man fühlte. Ich glaube, Schlange kann gut fühlen, oder? Also ich versuche immer so Tiere einzuordnen, in Hund riechen, Katze hören, Luchs, Adler sehen. Wie Luchs auf Wiedervorlage ist, oder was? Mal hinten anstecken. Luchs noch mal, morgen noch mal. Weiter. Und ich liebe das ja in Quiz-Sendungen, ich liebe ja, weiter. Und wenn es da mal so einen Supercut gäbe von allen, weiter, so dieses, ich weiß es nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, weiter, wie ist die Hauptstadt von Deutschland? Weiter. Weiter. Aber, und dann denkt man kurz, man weiß es, es gibt ja entschiedene Weiters und ich gebe auf im Laufe des Denkprozesses Weiters. Genau, ja. Ich mag aber auch die, die so richtig selbstbewusst sind.
Du gestehst ein, dass du es nicht weißt, aber mit dem, weiter.
Wer hat der Schrei gemalt? Weiter.
Das war so, genau, sofort weiter, Kopfschütteln, weiter, nie gehört, der Schrei und the fuck is this. Ich glaube auch, wenn ich in der Quizding wäre, ich würde mir den Gag erlauben, einfach nur immer weiter zu sagen, um zu gucken, wie viele Fragen haben die eigentlich.
Welcher Baum tritt am häufigsten auf in Deutschland? Weiter. Ah, okay, nicht so entschieden. Nicht so entschieden. In welchem Jahr war die französische Revolution? Weiter. Wer war der erste Mensch auf dem Mond? Weiter. Was ist die Hauptstadt von Frankreich? Weiter. Was ist deine Lieblingsfarbe? Weiter. und am Ende sagen die, wir haben keine Fragen mehr
weiter, weiter, ne es geht nicht mehr weiter. Weiter. Weiter. Eigentlich müsste man das... Schatz, wie war es in der Quizshow? Weiter. Man müsste das eigentlich sozial etablieren, dass wenn der sagt, ein wunderbares, prachtexemplates Fahrrad und du so weiter. Einfach Skip, einfach Skip, but next, nächstes Thema. Weiter. Möchtest du darüber reden, wie es dir gerade geht? Weiter. Ja. Du bist auch immer in dieser angespannten Quizstimmung. Aber mir gefällt es, es muss immer weitergehen. Genau, weiter ist ein gutes Wort. Weil es sagt auch aus, ich bin ready für die nächsten Tasks. Richtig. Vielleicht nicht, aber ich bin zumindest offen, mir die Frage mal anzuhören. Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Mindset zu sagen, das kann ich jetzt halt nicht, aber ich bin bereit fürs nächste. Weiter. Das war ja das Beste an dieser Clubhouse-Phase, es gab ja kurz diese App, die aufgetaucht ist, Clubhouse, so Live-Podcast, whatever, kurz, ähm, Leute haben gesprochen und man konnte sich da reinwählen und gucken und dann konnte man sich ja reinwählen, man konnte sich auch auf die Hand heben, dann konnte man auf die Bühne gehoben werden und vor allem gab es aber unten immer den Leave Quietly Button. Und das fand ich das Schönste und deswegen wünsche ich mir manchmal diese App zurück und wünsche ich mir erfolgreicher, weil es gibt einfach den Leave Quietly Button. Und das fand ich so schön. Immer dieses, das ist genau wie dieses Weiter, einfach so ein kleines Tool im Leben, so ein kleines Leave Quietly, raus, weg, weg. Ich wollte mir immer rückwärts wieder aus dem Haus geht. Ja, das ist richtig schön. Einfach raus. Ja, ich erinnere mich auch immer noch, ich war einmal in einem klassischen Konzert und da war so ein, und das ist ja wirklich mein Highlight immer noch, weil ich bin ja Ruheteilverfechter und ich glaube, da hatte ich einen Seelenverwandten gefunden, der während des Konzerts anscheinend raus musste, aber er wollte so sehr das Konzert nicht stören, dass er sich die Schuhe ausgezogen hat, die Schuhe in der Hand gehalten hat und auf Socken den Konzertsaal verlassen hat. Gut, er hatte Holzschuhe an, das muss man da beizeigen. Ja, aber ich meine, er war Stepptänzer, er hatte gleich einen Auftritt. Aber da habe ich mir gedacht, wow, das ist schon, das ist Leave Quietly. So muss man es machen im Leben, einfach langsam raus. In Köln ist ja über der Philharmonie ein großer Platz. Das ist ein bisschen so ein Baufehler, da darf man nicht drüber gehen, während unten das Orchester probt oder halt Aufstritte hat, weshalb dann Leute angestellt werden mit gelben Warnwesten, die sich dann um diesen grossen Platz stellen, damit niemand drüberläuft, weil es unten dann einfach hörbar wäre. Ja, oder Einstürz oder so, glaube ich auch. Ist das nicht auch eine Gefahr? Ich meine, es ist eher eine, nee, man darf ja drüber gehen, wenn unten. War das nicht so, dass das jetzt dauerhaft bewacht wird und nicht nur während Konzerten? Irgendwas habe ich da mal, okay, kann sein, aber jedenfalls bin ich dann da vorbeigelaufen. Es ist halt wirklich hundert Meter von hier, du bist nichts. Es ist wirklich nicht weit, aber ich bin dann da neulich lang gelaufen und habe das dann Freunden erzählt, die nicht aus der Stadt sind und habe denen dann erklärt, dass es dann nicht immer immer Idioten gibt, denen einfach drüber rennen, weil die machen ja dann nichts, also es ist nicht so, dass die bewaffnet wären, diese Menschen, die da rumstehen mit Warnwesten.
Und während ich denen erkläre, wie doof ich das finde, dass da Leute einfach drüber laufen, habe ich nicht gemerkt, dass ich eine Abkürzung gehe und links noch ein Mann war mit der Warnweste und ich einfach mit denen, während ich erzähle, wie bescheuert das ist, laufe ich über den Platz drüber, so abgekürzt, diese Runde, weshalb ich während mitten in dem Satz, und dann gibt es natürlich immer Idioten, die hier, schreit da mich der Typ und sagt, können Sie bitte aussen rumgehen? Ah, nice, perfekt, du auf deinem Fahrrad, da gibt es ja immer so ein bisschen Vollidioten, Entschuldigung, nicht mit Fahrrädern. Nicht mit dem Bulldozer jetzt hier drüberfahren. Aber da denke ich mir, ich meine, ich sage mal so, klassische Musik, das sind ja immer extrovertierte Komponisten, Dirigenten,
die immer so ein bisschen die Bandbreite noch erhöhen wollen.
Ja, wir denken an irgendwie,
wo dann die Trompeten sind im Nebenraum oder so.
Maler, maler das Zweite.
Oder du haust auf Metallstücke drauf.
Zum Beispiel?
Das ganze Publikum singt mit und so.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendeinen Komponisten,
der sagt, pass auf, wir stellen den Chor auf den Konzertsaal und die müssen dann irgendwie in einem Takt dann irgendwie marschieren oder singen, sodass man so von die Stimme der Engel, die Stimme der Götter, das ist doch mal ein Stilmittel, das klassische Konzertkomponisten mal benutzen können. Leute, macht das doch, Köln ist doch die Vorreiterstadt dafür. Malers Zweite ist ja wirklich so, und das muss man
sagen, ist die Zweite.
Er ist nicht bei 86.
Das ist Toy Story 2. Wir sind hier immer noch vor
2000. Wir haben noch viel zu erzählen.
Wir sind erst bei 2.
Und er hat sich überlegt, es gibt nicht
nur eine unglaublich
große Orchesterbesetzung,
es gibt auch noch ein
ganzes Orchester
ausserhalb des Raumes,
was ab und zu spielt.
Es gibt auch noch ein ganzes Orchester ausserhalb des Raumes, was ab und zu spielt. Es gibt eine Orgel, die am Ende einsetzt. Wir haben einen riesen Chor, der irgendwann kommt, erst ganz am Ende. Wir haben vier Solisten, wir haben aber auch noch vier Trompeten, die am Ende ausserhalb des Orchesters oben, die von oben spielen. Also er hat sich gedacht, Gimmick, einfach unten, das ist auch noch so ein Riesen, es gibt irgendwie drei Percussionisten, weil es so viel Percussion-Kram gibt. Aber da muss man sagen, zeigt er damit nicht am Ende, dass er inhaltlich nicht wirklich was zu sagen hat. Er hatte nichts. Er hatte nichts. Der hat nur ne ne ne ne ja, steht dann auf, während ihr das macht. Könnt ihr nicht so im Takt aufstehen und euch hinsetzen, die Trompeter oder sowas. Wir sind keine, wir machen keinen Sport. Ja, aber das ist halt ein Ausdruck, das ist, weißt du, das ist nochmal wichtiger, gar nichts. Er ist wie, so zehn Minuten vor Abgabe, vielleicht wird der Zeit schinden, nee, nee, wir brauchen übrigens noch ein zweites Orchester, ne? Das dauert jetzt aber einen Monat, bis wir es kriegen. Ja, okay, dann müssen wir halt so lange warten. Warum ist die Schriftgrösse der Noten so gross? Gustav, das ist jetzt eine Note pro Seite. Ja, aber was für eine Note, ne? Ja, es ist immer nur B. Ja, modern. B, B, B, B. Es ist halt, ja. Und das habe ich meine auch schon mal gehört. Was, wirklich? Ja, modern. Ja, und das habe ich mein Jahr schon mal gehört.
Was, wirklich?
Ja, aber da hat Gustav gesagt, bei der zweiten, ich verbrate alles.
Und dann kam die dritte und er dachte, fuck. Und die dritte ist dann ein Banjo.
Und sonst nichts.
Einfach so, da muss man eine Ansage machen, oh, ihr mochtet die zweite? Okay, jetzt ein Banjo. Nur ein Banjo. Ja, fuck it, fuck this. Einfach nur das. Fick die Kritiker. Kam gar nicht gut an, früher, wie es immer so ist. Heute wird es geliebt. Und ich fand es auch ganz toll. Das war die Nymphonie, wo ich die Karten gewonnen habe. Bei Twitch. Das war sehr lustig. Hat geklappt und ich kann es nur empfehlen. Geht in die zweite rein. Immer wenn die gespielt wird, geht da rein. Das ist fantastisch. Selbst für Leute, die gar nicht viel mit Musik anfangen können, es ist einfach wie so ein Gimmicky-Konzert.
Ja, oder schaut euch den Dungeons & Dragons Film an, den fand ich richtig lustig.
Im Ernst, nee, aber auch für Comedy-Fans, man muss sagen, der Film war primär lustig und ich fand ihn sehr, sehr lustig.
Und ich glaube auch Leute, die jetzt nicht so richtig viel Ahnung von Pen & Paper haben oder Fantasy. Ich glaub, rein als lustiger, humoristischer, humoriger, unterhaltsamer Film, wo ich mir so viel Popcorn in die Kiemen geschoben hab, als gäb's kein Morgen mehr. Ich hab die mir reingedrückt, also wow. Ist wirklich so ... Ich hab mir neulich Popcorn selber gemacht zu Hause. Oh, schwer, sehr schwer. Es macht so Spaß, gar nicht schwer, super einfach. Doch, sehr schwer. Es könnte nicht einfacher sein. Das ist das Einfachste, was ich jemals gemacht habe. Ja, aber wie kommt der Zucker dran? Gar nicht. Pass auf. Ich mache nur Roh. Pass auf, also, du machst sehr viel Kokosöl in den Topf, dann machst du es mega heiß, also wirklich, dass du denkst, du hast ein Hot Pot, Level 3. Dann machst du ganz viel, aber nicht zu viel, weil es ist erstaunlich, wie viel Popcorn das ist. Ihr denkt, es ist viel zu viel. Macht Popcorn rein, dann könnt ihr den Herd auch ausmachen, macht Deckel drauf und dann hört ihr es langsam rasseln. Ihr könnt auch vorher schon ein bisschen Salz reinmachen, unten ins Kokosöl, ich will es gern salzig, dann macht ihr obendrauf noch Salz, dann macht ihr ein bisschen Zucker rein, ist auch völlig okay. Salzig ist, nee, aber das ist das Problem, weil richtig geil ist ja eigentlich, wenn du es schaffst, dass der Zucker sich karamellisiert und darin die Popcorn sind, die dann aufpoppen und was so Karamell mitnehmen. Dann mach vorher in das Hokosöl Zucker rein.
Das Problem ist, dass Karamell sehr zäh ist und wenn da Karamell drin ist und diese Körner umschliesst, dann poppen die nicht mehr richtig auf, weil das zähe Karamell hält die fest.
Und das ist super schwer, weil am Ende hast zähe Karamell hält die fest.
Und das ist super schwer, weil am Ende hast du vielleicht super karamellige Popcorn, die aber einfach hart sind, oder du hast halt super fluffige Popcorn, an denen kaum Karamell ist. Es ist leider ein bisschen Widerspruch in sich. Und ich weiß wirklich nicht, wie man das im Kino macht, deswegen gehe ich immer wirklich auch gerne in Kinos und hole mir da Popcorn. oder, und das ist, sag ich mal, es gibt auch Kinos, die auch in Hotel sind,
wie geil ist das denn, dass du mal, es gibt auch Kinos, die auch ein Hotel sind.
Wie geil ist das denn, dass du im Hotel wohnen kannst und dir
dann einfach Popcorn unten holen kannst?
Wie gut ist das denn?
Warum ist nicht alles auch noch ein Kino?
Nee, warum ist nicht alles auch noch ein Hotel?
So, warum ist nicht, ich hab hier eine
Go-Kart-Bahn, Hotel. Ist auch ein Hotel.
Ja, einfach morgens aufwachen.
Krankenhaus, Hotel. Ist immer schon ein Hotel. Mit perfektem Frühstück. Nee, gute Frage. Wie macht man das, wem löst man das? Ich habe aber keinen, nicht Bock auf so Karanellpopcorn. Ich mache oben drauf noch ein bisschen Butter. Das ist so geil. Butter, geiles Salz, gutes Salz. Nehmen wir nicht das Tafel-Jod-Salz, sondern nehmt das Himalaya-Salz,
nehmt das gute. Bist du Herr Stephan
aus Berlin, kann das sein, dass du Chefkoch?
Ich bin Herr Stephan Level
1000 Koch.
Okay, ich wünsche
eine schöne Woche und euch
allen Gutes, ich hoffe, ihr
verfeilt nicht noch in die Prank-Lust von
Stephan Tietze, sondern haltet euch zurück und ansonsten
sehen wir uns in der nächsten Woche wieder.
Ich freue mich sehr darauf, denn es wird viel passieren in der Zeit.
Wir werden berichten.
Habt eine schöne Woche und stay safe.
Draußen ist eine wilde Welt und passt alle ein bisschen auf.
Haut rein, macht's gut, weiter, ciao.
Tschüssi.
It's the worst bell to Dutchem. Weiter. Das ist die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Schöne, die Sch